foreign
State Governor's site July 1st Governor
Jay Inslee has directed his cabinet
agencies to implement policies to
require their employees to be vaccinated
against covet 19.
the office of financial management will
begin the process of rulemaking and
engage in bargaining with labor
new mandates in July of 2022 when the
evidence is abundant and ever growing
that these vaccines are not what was
promised and are are indeed as the
preprint that we were just discussing
suggests are doing more harm than good
okay next next link I sent you Zach so
wait wait can I uh yes pause and suggest
something here
in terms of practicality right we are
getting a number of different signals on
a number of different channels that
suggest something that you and I uh
intuited up front
at the beginning of all of this vaccine
stuff before there was any evidence
which was that the DNA based vaccines
were likely to be much safer for various
reasons and so the fact is if you are in
a position where you are being forced to
take uh one of these vaccines right you
may have a very difficult choice to make
but
if you were to go with one of the
dna-based vaccines the
um
the Ben article that we discussed uh
several weeks back suggested that the
dna-based vaccines actually at least so
far show some benefit not all of which
comes from covid so there's a mystery
about uh why they might have a positive
effect and that could certainly reverse
Ben Christine Ben who's the author
um
but we have that piece of evidence we
have what I believe is going to turn out
to be correct which is that the
pseudo-uridine problem will not afflict
uh the the mrnas that result in Spike
protein
um
and so anyway a person and you have just
a simple fact that each of the
vaccination uh incidents seems to carry
some separate risk and so a vaccine that
requires one dose rather than two has a
benefit there as well so
um we are not giving medical advice but
were we faced with a difficult choice
and we understand that many people were
but choosing between vaccines so far
we've seen several independent reasons
to think that probably what risks exist
are reduced in uh in the case of those
yep and in Canada Zachary we are told
two doses are no longer enough this is
in Toronto Sun on July 4th Canadians now
required to get coveted shot every nine
months
ah that sounds like quite quite a
vaccine we got going there uh so uh
Health Minister Jean told reporters
um so so the Toronto Sun says if you
thought you were fully vaccinated think
again oh you guys are not seeing the
screen anymore
um now we can we can move on and so and
then finally in this little you know
this little Trio of okay Governor
insleans Washington state says actually
all state employees
um with some limitations need to be
vaccinated Canada is saying actually you
got to get boosters every nine months
and um Elmo Elmo is on it as well so uh
Zach if you want to show uh Elmo from
Sesame Street getting talking about his
vaccination status let's let's do this
background information on Elmo he's red
I was going to ask you because although
he seems red to me well and you can see
from the little screenshot that's
actually showed us his dad is also read
suggesting higher certainty of paternity
than you might have otherwise thought we
don't actually know the range of colors
within whatever
subspecies of Muppet Elmo might oh you
think I don't I thought all the Muppets
can't interbreed I don't I mean I guess
if Kermit and Miss Piggy right I mean
maybe it was just a tryst I don't know
maybe they didn't seen little frog pig
babies
right yeah oh yeah and then there's of
course haldane's rule the possibility
that the uh were they to have produced
hybrid Muppet Babies that the one that
was heterogametic would have been uh
uh born still would have been infertile
or short-lived oh boy it's tough too
with Kermit being a frog and all and the
incredibly High rate of polyploidy in uh
in frogs and you know just how is that
going to work with your genetic sex
determination over here with mammals and
then you're you know you got you got a
lot of crazy genetics going on this is
the worst frog mix it's worse than being
Star-Crossed it's being I don't know
felt crossed or something I felt crust
felt cross lovers yeah okay well I I
think that was a fine little uh Muppet
mating genetics we successfully avoided
dead air goodness um you have the video
to to show our audience now Zach
excellent yeah
hey getting your covet vaccine Elmo
[Music]
I had a lot of questions about Elmo
getting the covet vaccine was it safe
was it the right decision
I talked to our pediatrician so I could
make the right choice
I learned that Elmo getting vaccinated
is the best way to keep himself our
friends neighbors and everyone else
healthy and enjoying the things they
love oh Emma and baby David have a
question can we have a hug oh come here
son uh Emma loves you Daddy I love you
too
it's okay to have questions about
coveted vaccines for your kids get the
latest Van Dyke is that what those are
called those little goatees no that's a
goatee that's just a goatee that's just
a goat it's just a goatee yeah he's
looking pretty happy he's trying to get
oh he's here the hip dads with their
cute red kids and uh and just explain to
the kids this is going to keep you safe
it's going to keep your family and
friends safe it's going to keep your
community safe if you just get one of
these shots which oh don't pay any
attention to the data behind the curtain
uh and the papers and the researchers
who are actually finding that no no
this is not so this doesn't stop
transmission and it doesn't stop
infection and although lots of people
like to respond once they're sick by
saying well I'm sure glad I got the shot
because if I hadn't I sure would have
been sicker now on no basis whatsoever
like this seems to be the new like fly
in the Ukraine colors in your in your
Twitter bio like once you get covered
you're expected to say or a lot of
high-profile people say
at least I got boosted at least I got
vaccinated else I'd sure as [ __ ] be
sicker with covet right now how do you
know that yeah it's not true there's
like it has been said it has been said
by people who wear nice lab coats and
look to be authoritative on the matter
but they've never shown us any evidence
of this being true we've got a lot of
people proclaiming it to be true which
by the way is not how science Works no
and it is particularly disturbing to
hear this done via Elmo and to hear the
particular nonsense about this is the
best way to keep you Elmo safe and your
community etc etc because there was
never any implication from evidence that
this made children who were healthy
safer right and so the idea is this was
always about protecting people who were
vulnerable by vaccinating children at
unknown risk right which was never
acceptable
um what what sane rational decent
Society does such a thing but we've done
it without explaining that that's what
we're doing now we've put uh this into a
cute Muppet and the whole point the way
the thing is structured the whole idea
is that the child watching their you
know the cutest Muppet of all declaring
how proud he is and that his father did
have questions but they were all
answered okay to have questions it's
okay as long as you come to the same
answer we have told you to come to ask
all the questions you want but come to
the right answer right if you come to a
different answer then you're right wing
right and those questions were always
wrong right so the point is really using
manipulating I mean this is just like
the ice cream stuff and all of the
various tactics that were used they
offered ice cream to kids and it's
getting vaccinated and things like that
the point is manipulating children who
are of course in need of protection from
adults who wish to manipulate them for
so many reasons this is adults who are
wrong manipulating children so as to
override the legitimate questions that
their thinking parents might have and
the point is oh well it all ends up with
the parent deciding to vaccinate the
child who doesn't need it because he's
is a healthy young Muppet you know
um so yeah I guarantee you elbow didn't
need it Elmo didn't need it yeah no he's
a muppet he's a muppet um yeah the the
only basis on which Elmo
could arguably the other hand Elmo
wasn't harmed by it either on account of
he's a muppet well there's that but I'm
also thinking Elma has got to be
30 or 40.
um he's a metamorphic Muppet right he is
a Peter Murphy stuck in time he's a
Muppets stuck in time okay so anyway the
whole point is how diabolical is this
that that even at this point at which
any rational person should be able to
look at this and say look overall
safe no effective how crippled do you
have to make that term before it applies
to these
most appallingly ineffective vaccines
right you have to really bend that term
they have to be well it's effective at
something so go get it what is that
something it's not controlling the
pandemic right it's uh it's not keeping
you from giving it to your family or
getting it from them it's you know at
best it's to keep vulnerable people out
of the hospital and they're giving it to
people who aren't vulnerable right right
it's insane
foreign
[Music]